Heroes come in many forms.
In comic books, "hero" is often somebody who's got supernatural powers,...
...particularly some type of strength.
Humans, we're all pretty limited in our strength.
But our ability to see injustice and take it on that's really unbounded.
Now, for this epidemic, there really are exemplars...
...who sacrifice their safety or comfort helping society continue to operate.
First and foremost are the health workers who are dealing with lots of sick people and...
incredible overloads, and firemen, bus drivers,...
...people who keep the food supply chain working, even to be a clerk in a store,...
...we depend on these people to show up.
We see those efforts, and thank you for keeping us safe.